do you look at your career as part 1 and
part 2 which is before call me maybe and
after calling me no I don't I look at it
as this huge sort of gradual climb
before her breakthrough Carly started
her climb to fame as a contestant on
Canadian Idol I hope everybody else
boats you not through and I'd like to
assign you to a management a record deal
and have you come to Toronto work with
me instead and though she didn't win the
singing contest she did manage to snag a
record deal after her run in the show
her 2008 debut album tug of war may not
have been a huge hit but flash forward
three years later when she released her
biggest song today Justin Bieber wrote
on Twitter that it was the catchiest
song he'd ever heard he's really been a
huge part of my story my crazy supporter
to date with without her might I don't
know if I would still be kind of just
working away here in Canada so I have
nothing but gratitude towards him and
Justin posted a video lip-synching the
song with his famous friends including
his girlfriend at the time Selena Gomez
soon after everyone wanted to create
their own version of call me maybe even
Katy Perry
do you have a favorite right now the
Cookie Monster you got cookie dough
Jared baby
I'm still a kid at heart that was
red-headed waiting for a Star Wars one
are you Star Wars fan there was the Star
Wars
yeah there was a start when the song
went number one in 18 countries and was
featured on her second album kiss Carly
told Roz and a special trip to the
Bahamas that she was soaking in all her
newfound success it's so gratifying
because I know how much work the other
stuff was I know what it was like to so
literally like fold all my own shirts
for merch and like literally my sister
helped me make this terrible pace that
you put the posters up around town and
we could never get the combination of
flour and water right and always just
look like so ended like poster when
planning her next single one of the
things Carly wanted to maintain was call
me maybe his light-hearted spirit the
idea that I've had some really
unexpected male characters sing the song
instead of me but her manager Scooter
Braun put the concept to the next
luckyyyy called me back a couple months
later I was like but I'm Tom Hanks
fiance because I just had dinner with
him and he's like jumping on the idea
and I thought it was a joke it's like
this is a really mean joke but in fact
you come through and it was the most
surreal awesome day of my life 2015
Carly released her third album emotion
and though it wasn't a runaway
commercial hit it received near
universal praise from music critics who
loved the album's 80s 5 there was
absolutely undeniable pressure after
call me maybe but I had a really good
group of people around me some some
heroes I like to call them who who sat
down with me and just said you can look
at this as pressure you can look at this
as an opportunity to show what we know
you have which is disability to write
songs outside of just that one and just
this past year Carly released another
album jam-packed with hits called
dedicate every single time I'm about to
see you I spend two days before and at
least two days after with all of your
songs stuck in my head
oh I'm sorry how often are your song
stuck in your head or do you try and
push them out I mean when I'm working on
a song it will continually run through
my head and usually the parts that I
want to fix until they get it right are
you obsessive I'm a bit of a
perfectionist when it comes to music I
think it's a fun obsession though I I
couldn't be in this business if I wasn't
in love with it
to